From PRI, Public Radio International.
来自国际公共广播电台（PRI）。
Public radio.
公共广播。
Public--
公共——
Radio International.
国际广播。
--Radio International.
——国际广播。
One more time.
再来一次。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，欢迎收听《美国生活》。
Well, it was Danielle's cousin, Lynn, who said it best. She said that Danielle and I had put ourselves into the kind of situation that 1,000 comedies had been built on, situation comedies, screwball comedies, every kind of TV, theatre, movie, drama thing. We had done that. We had done that to ourselves.
嗯，丹妮尔的表妹琳恩说得最好。她说丹妮尔和我把自己陷入了一种源于一千部喜剧的境地，情景喜剧、疯狂喜剧，以及各种电视剧、戏剧、电影和剧情片里都会有的那种境地。我们确实这么做了。是我们自己把自己搞成这样的。
And how did we not know? Here we were, Danielle and I. We used to be involved. And it was our first time together as just friends.
我们怎么会不知道呢？当时丹妮尔和我在一起。我们曾经交往过。而那次是我们分手后第一次以朋友身份相处。
Just friends. Just friends. You know you are in trouble when the word "just" appears in front of the word "friend." It's almost hard to think of a context where those two words are used together, a sentence constructed-- unless you're using the word "just" in some radically different way, like, "I think the verdict was just. Friends may disagree." If they have nothing to do with each other, maybe it's OK. But-- but, but, but.
仅仅是朋友。仅仅是朋友。当你意识到“仅仅”这个词出现在“朋友”之前时，你就知道麻烦来了。很难想象这两个词在一起的语境，除非你用一种完全不同的方式使用“仅仅”这个词，比如，“我认为判决是公正的（just）。朋友们可能会有不同意见。”如果它们彼此毫无关联，也许还可以。但是——但是，但是，但是。
Because automatically, it implies a negotiation's happening, just friends. Friends is like a state of being. Friends is like there's a road. There are houses. People are friends. So when you put "just" in front of it, it suggests the imbalance. And that's where you get the screwball comedy aspect.
因为这自动暗示了一种协商正在发生，仅仅是朋友。朋友是一种存在状态。朋友就像有一条路。路边有房子。人们是朋友。所以当你把“仅仅”放在前面时，它就暗示了一种失衡。这就是你从疯狂喜剧中得到的那个层面。
All right, I'm going to try to keep the mundane personal information to a minimum here so we can focus on the bigger, universal truths this story may offer. Briefly, some facts, though. OK, Danielle and I had been broken up for half a year. And she lived in New York City. I lived in Chicago. And we talked on the phone several times a week.
好了，我尽量把平凡的个人信息降到最低，这样我们就可以专注于这个故事可能提供的更宏大、普遍的真理。不过先简单说点事实。好吧，丹妮尔和我已经分手半年了。她住在纽约市，我住在芝加哥。我们每周通几次电话。
In other words, that kind of weird, post-relationship situation where there's no more sex, but you depend on each other for all your emotional needs. So all the work of the relationship, but none of the sheer physical pleasure. That was our thing.
换句话说，就是那种奇怪的、后关系状态，没有了性，但你们在情感需求上仍然依赖彼此。所以拥有了关系中的所有负担，却没有了纯粹的身体快乐。这就是我们的状态。
Anyway, so two days before I came to New York City to visit friends there-- real friends, not just friends, just normal friends-- and Danielle, she informs me that there's a guy that she had started dating. 'I like him," she said. "I really like him." And then two days later, I found myself in New York City.
总之，就在我去纽约市拜访朋友——真正的朋友，不是那种“仅仅是朋友”，而是正常的朋友——的两天前，丹妮尔告诉我她开始和一个男人约会了。“我喜欢他，”她说，“我真的很喜欢他。”然后两天后，我就在纽约市了。
And your wish in this kind of situation is you want a sense of, OK, we're going to be friends. It's going to be OK. We're going to see how this new thing between us feels. And we're trying to hang out and be buddies. And that's how we ended up in Saks Fifth Avenue, where the first moment of our screwball comedy weekend occurred.
在这种情况下，你的愿望是想要一种感觉，好吧，我们要成为朋友了。会没事的。我们要看看我们之间这种新关系感觉如何。我们试着闲逛，做伙伴。就这样，我们来到了萨克斯第五大道百货公司，我们那出疯狂喜剧周末的第一个瞬间就发生在那里。
So we're walking through that big, cold-floored Fifth Avenue store, the mannequins everywhere and Anne Klein and Anne Klein Two and Anne Klein Contemporaries-- there are actually three different Anne Klein departments at Saks Fifth Avenue-- and all the other designers. And it wasn't too crowded, and it wasn't too empty. And she was walking ahead of me, just a step or two ahead of me, never quite meeting my eye.
于是我们走在那家地板冰冷的大型第五大道商店里，到处都是人体模型，有安妮·克莱因、安妮·克莱因二代、安妮·克莱因当代系列——萨克斯第五大道百货里实际上有三个不同的安妮·克莱因专柜——还有所有其他设计师的作品。里面人不多也不少。她走在我前面，只比我快一两步，从不与我对视。
And I realized that, oh, that's the way this has been for an hour or two, isn't it? When we were walking up the street, it was like that. She wasn't quite meeting my eye. She wasn't quite talking to me. It was like she was holding a certain emotional distance.
我意识到，哦，这就是过去一两个小时以来的状态，不是吗？我们走在街上时就是这样。她没有和我对视。她也没有怎么跟我说话。就像她保持着某种情感距离。
And that's the thing that gets to you. It's not the big picture. No, we're not together. No, we have no future together. It's the little picture. No, you won't meet my eyes anymore.
这就是让人难受的地方。不是全局。不，我们没有在一起。不，我们没有未来。而是细节。不，你不再看我的眼睛了。
And in each of our histories of love, who has not played both parts in this drama? Both parts, who hasn't been both people in this picture at one time or another? The person walking a little briskly ahead, not meeting the eye of the other person, and the person walking behind, a little over-eager, a little extra edge of anxiousness, wanting to make the connection, a little bit like an eager puppy. The other person ahead, a little bit put off by the yapping of this puppy. No matter how subtle and dignified and interesting that yapping happens to be, just kind of not wanting to deal with this, not wanting to face this situation, walking ahead about three paces. Who among us has not been on both sides of that?
在我们的恋爱史中，谁没有扮演过这场戏里的两个角色？两个角色，谁没有在某个时候成为图片中的那两个人之一呢？那个走得稍快、不去看对方眼睛的人，以及那个走在后面、有点过于急切、带着一丝焦虑、想要建立联系、有点像渴望关注的小狗一样的人。前面那个人，被这只小狗的叫声弄得有点烦。无论这种叫声多么微妙、庄重和有趣，对方只是不想应付，不想面对这种情况，自顾自地往前走了三步。我们之中谁没有处于过这两个角色中呢？
So she's looking for clothes. And she has this new guy she's seeing. And she's carrying the clothes. And we're looking for a dressing room. And we find a dressing room. And we stand outside the dressing room.
所以她在挑衣服。她有了一个正在交往的新男友。她拿着衣服。我们在找试衣间。我们找到了一个试衣间。我们站在试衣间外面。
And it's an automatic setup situation. Do I come into this dressing room and watch you try on-- she's like, "I want you to see these clothes." OK, do I come into the dressing room? There's something inherently odd and awkward about not coming in, because what is in there that I have not seen before? But there's something inherently awkward about coming in as well because things have changed.
这是一种自动设置的情况。我要进这个试衣间看着你试穿吗——她说，“我想让你看看这些衣服。”好吧，我要进试衣间吗？不进去显得很不自然，很尴尬，因为里面有什么是我没见过的呢？但进去也显得很不自然，因为一切都变了。
Either way, there's a problem. So we stood there in the door of this dressing room and composed the orbits that we're riding against each other, right? We looked at the two little orbits and decided, OK, I'll go in.
无论哪种方式，都有问题。所以我们站在试衣间门口，构成了我们彼此环绕的轨道，对吧？我们看了看那两个小轨道，决定，好吧，我进去。
And she takes off her clothes and tries on these clothes. And the clothes she has gotten are the following. There's a little lacy, clingy, sort of stretched top of black, kind of like a black lace thing that you would wear maybe a jacket over to cover your nipples. And so she's got that on.
她脱下衣服，开始试穿这些衣服。她拿的衣服如下：一件小巧的、紧身的、有点弹性的黑色上衣，就像那种黑色蕾丝装，你可能需要再穿一件夹克来遮住乳头。所以她穿上了那个。
And she's got this little miniskirt. And while we've been walking around Saks, she's been saying, "I've got to find a miniskirt. I really need a black miniskirt." She just switched jobs. And so she's trying on this miniskirt. And she's looking very cute. She's looking adorable.
她还有一条超短裙。当我们在萨克斯逛的时候，她一直在说：“我得找条超短裙。我真的需要一条黑色超短裙。”她刚换了工作。所以她正在试这条超短裙。她看起来非常可爱。她看起来非常迷人。
And suddenly, she's trying on the miniskirt, so I say, "Well, honey, you have a miniskirt. You have that black pleated miniskirt. I've seen you in that miniskirt a million times." She says, "No, no, no, no. No, no. That miniskirt comes down to here." And she indicates a spot maybe an inch above her knee. "I need a miniskirt that's a lot shorter. I need it to come to here." And she indicates a spot maybe, I don't know, six inches, eight inches, above her knee. Six inches. A lot higher. And there's a pause. And she looks at me and says, "Well, I wouldn't wear this to work."
突然，她正在试这条超短裙，于是我说：“亲爱的，你有一条超短裙啊。你有那条黑色百褶短裙。我见你穿过那条短裙一百万次了。”她说：“不，不，不，不。不，不。那条短裙到这儿。”她指了指膝盖上方大约一英寸的地方。“我需要一条短得多的超短裙。我需要它到这儿。”她指了指膝盖上方大概六到八英寸的地方。六英寸。短得多。一阵沉默。她看着我说：“嗯，我穿这个可没法去上班。”
So I start to think to myself, "What am I doing here? Who are these clothes for?" And I picture the guy who she's going out with. And I picture pretty much him looking at the clothes, her trying to look cute in the clothes, her looking very cute in the clothes. I pretty much picture everything you can picture.
于是我开始想，“我在这儿干什么？这些衣服是给谁穿的？”我脑海中浮现出她正在交往的那个男人的样子。我几乎能想象到他看着这些衣服，她试着穿这些衣服看起来很可爱，她穿这些衣服看起来非常可爱的样子。我几乎能想象到你能想象到的一切。
And I'm sitting down on the chair. There's a little chair in the dressing room. And so there's Danielle, looking adorable in her little clothes, and kind of absorbed in looking at it this way and that. And I'm going to try to describe the gesture that occurs next. Imagine me, a tallish sort of guy, slumped in this chair, leaning back in this chair in this dressing room. And I hope I can convey this over the radio, the motion she does next.
我坐在椅子上。试衣间里有一把小椅子。丹妮尔穿着她的小衣服看起来很可爱，沉浸在从各个角度打量自己的样子中。我试着描述接下来发生的动作。想象一下，一个高个子男人，瘫在这把椅子上，往后靠在这试衣间的椅子里。我希望我能通过广播传达出她接下来的那个动作。
I had been feeling like she kind of wasn't seeing me. When we were walking around the store, I felt a little bit ignored, like not seen. And I'm sitting in the dressing room thinking, "You know, I should really leave this dressing room. I don't really need to see this right now."
我一直觉得她好像没看见我。当我们走在商店里时，我感到有点被忽略了，好像被当成了空气。我坐在试衣间里想，“你知道吗，我真的应该离开这个试衣间。我现在没必要看这些。”
And just as I'm thinking this thought, she takes off the miniskirt, and she just kind of tosses it onto the chair, as if it were an empty chair. But in fact, I'm sitting on it. So she just tosses the skirt onto me.
就在我产生这个想法时，她脱下了那条超短裙，随手扔在了椅子上，就好像那是一把空椅子。但事实上，我正坐在上面。所以她就把裙子扔在了我身上。
And suddenly, she looks up. And in horror, actually, I have to say, to her credit, in actual horror, and sees this skirt kind of sitting on my chest, because I'm slumped backwards. And so there's this semi-horizontal surface. And this skirt is now sitting on my chest, looking ridiculous. And suddenly, she realizes exactly what she's done. And she says to me, "Oh, no. You're going to talk about this on your radio show, aren't you?"
突然，她抬头看了一眼。真的，我得说，她感到很惊恐，确实很惊恐，看到这条裙子盖在我的胸口上，因为我正往后瘫着。所以这是一个半水平的平面。这条裙子现在就盖在我的胸口上，看起来很滑稽。突然，她意识到自己做了什么。她对我说：“噢，不。你要在你的广播节目里说这件事，对吧？”
Well, of course, this is my radio show. It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And by the way, I did get Danielle's permission to talk about this on the radio. Otherwise I would not be here talking about it with you today.
嗯，当然，这是我的广播节目。这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。顺便说一句，我确实征得了丹妮尔的同意才在广播里谈论这件事。否则我今天就不会在这里和你谈论它了。
Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's theme is Get Over It. We bring you three stories of people who have a hard time letting go of the past. Act One of our program, the act we're in, right now, is nonfiction. Act Two is fiction. Act Three is a little documentary.
每周节目中，我们当然会选一个主题。今天的主题是“走出来”。我们为你带来三个关于那些难以放下过去的人的故事。我们现在的这一幕，第一幕，是纪实文学。第二幕是小说。第三幕是一个小纪录片。
And I bring up what happened between me and Danielle because I think that she and I stumbled upon a few things that happen universally in the "get over it" situation. For one thing, one of the most delicate aspects of this situation is how much information do you want about your ex-girlfriend's new boyfriend, or your ex-whatever's new whatever?
我提起丹妮尔和我之间发生的事，是因为我觉得我们偶然发现了一些在“走出来”的过程中普遍发生的事情。首先，这种情况最微妙的方面之一是，你有多想了解前女友的新男友，或者前任的现任？
My friend Julie told me a story in mourning that went as follows. She had hungrily devoured every piece of information she could get about one of her ex-boyfriends' new girlfriends. And at one point, he told her that the girl had a dog. And somehow, that detail made Julie crazy.
我的朋友朱莉在哀伤中告诉我一个故事，内容如下。她曾如饥似渴地搜集关于她前男友新女友的每一条信息。有一次，他告诉她那个女孩有一条狗。不知为何，那个细节让朱莉快疯了。
It made her feel like, "Oh my god, this is a person with her life worked out completely. This is a person whose life is so much better than mine. This person has a dog, which means that they have a life that can surround a dog. And the fact that they have a dog means that they're a person capable of love. And it means that they're a person in a stable situation, with a home where they can have a dog." And suddenly, everything came into question about him and her and the girl. And I wanted to avoid that. But I wanted information. And I don't know exactly why, but there was a powerful herd of stampeding horses within me, wanting information. And I found myself asking questions.
这让她觉得，“天哪，这是一个生活已经完全安排妥当的人。这是一个生活比我好得多的人。这个人有一条狗，这意味着她拥有能够照顾一条狗的生活。而且她有一条狗，意味着她是一个有能力去爱的人。这意味着她处在一个稳定的环境中，有一个可以养狗的家。”突然，关于他、她和那个女孩的一切都成了问题。我本来想避免那种情况，但我还是想要信息。我不知道具体原因，但我内心有一群狂奔的马，渴望获得信息。我发现自己不断地问问题。
And I know, "Listen very carefully to these questions. Listen very carefully, Ira. Because whatever it is that you're asking will indicate something about yourself. And the order you ask them will indicate something. You can learn something here." And I listened. And I said to myself, OK.
我知道，“仔细听这些问题，艾拉。一定要仔细听。因为无论你问什么，都会透露出关于你自己的某些信息。而你提问的顺序也会透露出某些信息。你可以在这里学到东西。”我听着。我对自己说，好吧。
"How old is he?" "He's 28." And OK, that one made sense. The age difference between Danielle and I had been kind of a big issue. And so I was trying to gauge where this new guy fit into the geography of that old, familiar landscape.
“他多大？”“他28岁。”好吧，那个问题说得通。丹妮尔和我的年龄差距曾经是个大问题。所以我试着评估这个新男人在那个熟悉的老地貌中处于什么位置。
See, that's part of what this is about. You have this map of an emotional city that you've built with another person. And you want to figure out, well, where are they on the map now?
你看，这就是原因的一部分。你拥有你与另一个人建立的情感城市的地图。而你想要弄清楚，好吧，他们现在在地图上的什么位置？
So my second question was going to be, "So what's he do? What's he do for a living?" But you know how every now and then, you'll read an article, or somebody at a party will say, "Isn't it shallow?" They'll say, "Isn't it shallow that when people want to know about other people, the first question they ask is, 'What do they do for a living?' Isn't that so shallow? Doesn't that indicate what a shallow group of people we are?"
所以我的第二个问题本来是，“那么他是做什么的？他从事什么职业？”但你知道人们偶尔会读到一篇文章，或者派对上有人会说，“这不肤浅吗？”他们会说，“当人们想了解别人时，第一个问题就是‘他是做什么工作的？’这不肤浅吗？这不说明我们是一群肤浅的人吗？”
And I thought, I don't want to fall into that trap. I don't want to fall into that trap of just equating people with their jobs. You don't want to think we are our jobs. That's just a shallow sort of thing.
我想，我不想掉进那个陷阱。我不想掉进把人和他们的工作划等号的陷阱。你不想认为我们就是我们的工作。那只是肤浅的东西。
So I sidestepped that question and came up with another question. The question I found myself asking-- I don't know where this came from-- was, "Is he a Jew?" I've been to services, what, once in the last 15 years? "Is he a Jew?"
所以我避开了那个问题，提出了另一个问题。我发现自己问的问题——我不知道这从哪儿来的——是，“他是犹太人吗？”我在过去15年里去过几次礼拜？“他是犹太人吗？”
I think what I meant by it was is he a member of my tribe? Is he like me? Is he like me, honey? Honey, you're seeing somebody else? Is he like me? He must be like me if you're seeing him, right? The only person you could be interested in is me, so he must be like me.
我想我问的意思是他是我的族人吗？他像我吗？他像我吗，亲爱的？亲爱的，你在和别人约会？他像我吗？你对他感兴趣，他肯定得像我，对吧？你唯一可能感兴趣的人就是我，所以他肯定得像我。
He was not a Jew.
他不是犹太人。
Now, I would like to tell you, beloved radio listener, that this phase of jealousy and competitiveness passed quickly on my part, that I moved with grace and ease into the world of just friends. I would like to say that. But one of the rules of getting over it, in fact, maybe the main rule of getting over it, is that you cannot choose the time and place. You cannot will it to happen. You cannot think, "OK, now. I have the right attitude right now. I'm over it. I'm ready. I'm over it, and it's now."
现在，我真希望能告诉你，亲爱的听众，我那段嫉妒和竞争的阶段很快就过去了，我优雅而从容地进入了“仅仅是朋友”的世界。我真希望我能那么说。但走出来的规则之一，事实上，也许是走出来最主要的规则，就是你不能选择时间和地点。你不能强迫它发生。你不能想，“好吧，现在。我现在有正确的心态了。我走出来了。我准备好了。我走出来了，就是现在。”
It's like when Jesus returns. I say this to you as a Jew. It's like when Jesus returns. None will know the exact day or hour. It can come like a thief in the night, the getting over it. Well, coming up in just a little bit, another story of somebody trying to get over it, trying to will himself to get over it, with exactly as much success as you would expect anybody to have who tries. Stay with us.
就像耶稣再临一样。我作为一个犹太人对你说这句话。就像耶稣再临一样。没人知道确切的日子或时刻。走出来这件事，可能就像深夜里的贼一样悄然而至。好了，过一会儿我们会有另一个故事，关于某人试图走出来，试图强迫自己走出来，结果和你预期的一样。请继续收听。
Act Two, Wishing for Amnesia. Well, this next story of someone unable to get over it comes from George Saunders, his amazing and sad and funny book, CivilWarLand in Bad Decline. This story is called "Offloading for Mrs. Schwartz."
第二幕，渴望失忆。这个关于某人无法走出来的故事来自乔治·桑德斯的书，他那部精彩、悲伤又好笑的作品《内战乐园在衰退》。这个故事叫《帮施瓦茨太太卸载》。
Elizabeth always thought the fake stream running through our complex was tacky. Whenever I'd sit brooding beside it after one of our fights, she'd hoot down at me from the balcony. Then I'd come in, and we'd make up. Oh, would we. I think of it. I think of it and think of it. Finally, in despair, I call GuiltMasters.
伊丽莎白总是觉得我们小区里那条假溪流很俗气。每当我因为我们的争吵而坐在溪边沉思时，她就会从阳台上对我大喊大叫。然后我进去，我们就和好了。噢，我们会和好的。我想起它。我一遍又一遍地回想。最后，在绝望中，我拨通了“负罪大师”的电话。
GuiltMasters are Jean and Bob Fleen, a brother/sister psychiatric practice. In their late-night TV ads, they wear cowls and capes and stand on either side of a sobbing, neurotic woman in sweater and slacks. By the end of the bit, she's romping through a field of daisies.
“负罪大师”是吉恩和鲍勃·弗林，一对兄妹经营的心理诊所。在他们的深夜电视广告里，他们穿着斗篷，站在一个穿着毛衣和休闲裤、哭泣、神经质的女人两边。广告结尾，她已经在雏菊丛中欢快地奔跑了。
I get Jean Fleen. I tell her I've done a bad thing I can't live with. She says I've called the right place. She says there's nothing so shameful it can't be addressed by GuiltMasters.
我接通了吉恩·弗林的电话。我告诉她我做了一件我无法接受的坏事。她说我打对了地方。她说没有什么是“负罪大师”解决不了的可耻之事。
I take a deep breath and spill my guts. There's a silence from Jean's end. Then she asks can I hold.
我深吸一口气，全盘托出。吉恩那边沉默了。然后她问我能不能稍等。
Upbeat muzak comes on. Several minutes later, Bob comes on and asks can they call me back. I wait by the phone, one hour, two hours, all night, nothing.
响起了欢快的轻音乐。几分钟后，鲍勃上线了，问他们能不能回电给我。我守在电话旁，一小时，两小时，整夜，什么都没有。
The sun comes up. Brad from Complex Grounds turns on the bubbler and the white water begins to flow. I don't shower. I don't shave. I put on the same pants I had before.
太阳升起来了。小区场地的布拉德打开了喷泉，白色的水开始流淌。我没洗澡。没刮胡子。穿上了和之前一样的裤子。
It's too much. Three years since her death, and still I'm a wreck. I think of fleeing the city. I think of working on a shrimper or setting myself on fire downtown. Instead, I go to work.
太多了。她去世三年了，我还是个残废。我想逃离这个城市。我想去捕虾船上工作，或者在市中心自焚。相反，我去上班了。
In spite of my problems, personal interactive holography marches on. All morning, I hopefully dust. Nobody comes in.
尽管我有问题，个人互动全息技术仍在发展。整个上午，我满怀希望地擦灰。没有人进来。
At noon, I work out a little tension by running amok in one of my modules. I choose Bowling with the Pros. A holographic smoothie in a blazer greets me and affably asks if I'm as tired as he is of perennially overhooking the ball, when what I really need is to consistently throw strikes. I tell him, "Piss off." In a more sophisticated module, he'd ask why the hostility, but my equipment is outdated. And instead, he looks confused and tries to shake my hand.
中午，我在其中一个模块里疯狂乱跑来缓解紧张。我选择了“职业保龄球”。一个穿着西装的全息帅哥迎接我，友好地问我是不是厌倦了总是投出弧线球，而我真正需要的是稳定地投出全中。我告诉他，“滚开。”在更高级的模块里，他会问为什么有敌意，但我的设备过时了。于是他看起来很困惑，试图和我握手。
What crappy verisimilitude. No wonder I'm in the red. No wonder my rent's overdue.
多蹩脚的逼真度。难怪我亏损。难怪我的房租逾期了。
He asks, isn't bowling a lovely recreation? I tell him I'm in mourning. He says the hours spent in a bowling alley with friends certainly make for some fantastic memories years down the line. I tell him my life's in the crapper. He grins and says, "Let's bowl. Let's go in and bowl. Let's go in and bowl a few frames with the pros." I take him by the throat. Of course he dysfunctions. Of course I'm automatically unbooted.
他问，保龄球不是一项可爱的娱乐吗？我告诉他我在服丧。他说在保龄球馆和朋友度过的时光肯定会在多年后留下美妙的回忆。我告诉他我的生活糟透了。他咧嘴一笑说，“来打球吧。进去打几局。进去和职业选手打几局。”我掐住他的喉咙。当然他故障了。当然我被自动踢出了系统。
I doff my headset and dismount the treadmill. Once again, it's just me and my failing shop. Once again, the air reeks of microwave popcorn. Once again, I am only who I am.
我摘下耳机，走下跑步机。又是只有我和我那失败的商店。又是空气里弥漫着微波炉爆米花的味道。又是只有我本人。
Wonderful, I think, you fouled your own $400 module. And I have. So I trash it. I write it off to grief management and go to lunch. I opt for an auto-dispensed FreightFurter. Of course, I over-microwave, and the paper cowcatcher melds with the bun, and the little engineer's face runs down his overalls. It's even more inedible than unusual. I chuck it. I can't afford another. I chuck it and go wait for my regulars.
太棒了，我想，你搞坏了你自己的400美元模块。我已经搞坏了。所以我把它扔了。我把它记作悲伤管理，然后去吃午饭。我选择了自动分发的“货运香肠”。当然，我加热时间过长，纸质牛排捕手和面包融在一起，工程师的小脸沿着他的背带裤流了下来。它比往常更难吃。我把它扔了。我买不起第二个。我把它扔了，回去等着我的常客。
At 2:00, Mr. Bomphil comes in looking guilty and as always, requests Violated Prom Queen, then puts on high heels and selects Treadmill Three. Treadmill Three is behind a beam, so he's free to get as worked up as he likes, which is very. I try not to hear him moan. I try not to hear him call each football team member by name.
下午2点，邦菲尔先生满脸愧疚地进来，一如既往地要求玩“被玷污的舞会皇后”，然后穿上高跟鞋，选择了三号跑步机。三号跑步机在横梁后面，所以他可以随心所欲地发泄，而且非常疯狂。我尽量不听他的呻吟。我尽量不听他喊出每个橄榄球队员的名字。
He's followed by Theo Kiley, an appliance salesman who lays down a ream of Frigidaire specs and asks for Legendary American Killers Stalk You. I strap on his headset. I insert his module. For 20 minutes, he hems and haws with Clyde Barrow. Finally, he slips up and succumbs to a burst of machine gun fire, then treats himself to a Sprite.
紧接着是西奥·凯利，一个电器推销员，他放下了一沓弗里吉代尔说明书，要求玩“传奇美国杀手潜行”。我给他戴上耳机。我插入他的模块。20分钟里，他和克莱德·巴罗磨磨蹭蹭。最后，他失误了，死于一连串机枪扫射，然后请自己喝了一瓶雪碧。
"Phew," he says. "Next time, I'll know to avoid the topic of his mom." I remind him he's got an outstanding bill. He says thanks. He says his bill and his ability to match wits with great criminals are the only outstanding things he's got.
“呼，”他说，“下次我会记得避开关于他妈妈的话题。”我提醒他有一笔未付的账单。他说谢谢。他说他的账单和他与伟大的罪犯比拼智力的能力是他仅有的突出事物。
We laugh. We laugh some more. He shakes his head and leaves. I curse him under my breath and close up early and return to my lonely home.
我们笑了。我们又笑了一会儿。他摇着头离开了。我低声咒骂他，提前关门，回到我孤独的家中。
The next day, Mrs. Gaither from corporate comes to town. Midway through my Significant Accomplishments Assessment, armless Mr. Feltriggi comes to the door and, as usual, rings the bell with his face. I let him in and he unloads his tote bag of cookbooks for sale. Today it's Crazy Cajun Carnival and Going Bananas with Bananas: a Caribbean Primer. But I know what he really wants. With my eyes, I tell him, "Wait."
第二天，来自总部的盖瑟太太来到镇上。就在我的重大成就评估进行到一半时，没胳膊的费尔特里吉先生来到门口，像往常一样用脸按响了门铃。我让他进来，他卸下装满待售食谱的手提袋。今天是《疯狂卡津嘉年华》和《香蕉香蕉：加勒比海入门》。但我知道他真正想要的是什么。我用眼神告诉他，“等等。”
Finally, Gaither finishes raking my subpar disbursement ledger over the coals and goes across the mall to O My God for some vintage religious statuary. I slip the headset on Feltriggi and run Youth Roams Kansas Hometown, 1932. It's all homemade bread and dirt roads and affable dogcatchers.
最后，盖瑟耙完了我不合格的支出账单，走到商场对面去买一些老式的宗教雕像。我给费尔特里吉戴上耳机，运行了《1932年堪萨斯少年漫游》。全都是自制面包、土路和友好的捕狗员。
What a sweet grin appears. He greets each home towner with his ghost limbs and beams at the chirping of the holographic birds. He kneels awhile in Mrs. Lawler's larder, sniffing spices that remind him of his mother, elbow-deep in flour. He drifts out to the shaded yard and discusses fascism with the iceman near some swaying wheat.
出现了多么甜美的微笑。他用鬼魂手臂向每个家乡人打招呼，对全息鸟儿的鸣叫报以微笑。他在劳勒太太的储藏室里跪了一会儿，闻着香料味，这让他想起他母亲，肘部深陷在面粉里。他飘到树荫下的院子里，在摇曳的麦田边和卖冰人讨论法西斯主义。
His posture changes for the better. He laughs aloud. He's young again, and the thresher has yet to claim his arms.
他的姿势变好了。他大声笑了起来。他又年轻了，脱粒机还没有夺走他的手臂。
Gaither comes back with a St. Sebastian cookie jar. I nudge Feltriggi and tell him that's all for today. I take off his headset, and he offers me a cookbook in payment. I tell him, forget it. I tell him that's what friends are for. It's $70 a session, and he knows it. He rams his head into my chest as a sign of affection.
盖瑟带着一个圣塞巴斯蒂安饼干罐回来了。我推了推费尔特里吉，告诉他今天就到这儿了。我摘下他的耳机，他付给我一本食谱作为报酬。我告诉他，算了。我告诉他这就是朋友的意义。那是每次70美元，他知道这一点。他把头撞在我的胸口作为亲昵的表现。
"That type of a present surely has to deflate revenues," Gaither says primly as Feltriggi goes out.
“那种礼物肯定会降低收入，”费尔特里吉离开时，盖瑟刻薄地说。
"No lie," I say. "That's why I nearly beat him up every time he comes in here."
“没撒谎，”我说，“这就是为什么他每次进来我几乎都要揍他一顿。”
"I'm not sure that's appropriate," she says.
“我不确定这是否合适，”她说。
"Me neither," I say. "That's why I usually don't really do it."
“我也不确定，”我说，“这就是为什么我通常并不真的这么做。”
"I see," she says. "Let's talk briefly about personal tragedy. No one's immune. But at what point must mourning cease? In your case, apparently never."
“我明白了，”她说，“让我们简单谈谈个人悲剧。没人能免疫。但在什么点上必须停止哀悼？在你的情况下，显然永远不会。”
I think, "You never saw Elizabeth lanky and tan and laughing in Napa." "I like your cookie jar," I say. "Very well," she says. "Seal your own doom."
我想，“你从来没见过伊丽莎白在纳帕那样苗条、黝黑、欢笑的样子。”“我喜欢你的饼干罐，”我说。“很好，”她说，“为你自己的厄运封印吧。”
She says she's shocked at the dryness of my treadmill bearings and asks if I've ever heard of oil. She sighs and gives me her number at the Quality Inn in case I think of anything that might argue against franchise agreement cancellation. Then out she goes, sadly shaking her head.
她说她对我的跑步机轴承的干涩感到震惊，问我有没有听说过润滑油。她叹了口气，给了我她在品质酒店的号码，以防我想到任何可以反对取消特许经营协议的理由。然后她走出去，悲伤地摇着头。
It's only my livelihood. It's only every cent Elizabeth left me. I load up my mobile pack. I select my happiest modules. Then I go off to my real job, my penance, my albatross.
这可是我的生计。这是伊丽莎白留给我的每一分钱。我装好我的移动背包。我选择了最快乐的模块。然后我去干我的真正工作，我的忏悔，我的累赘。
Rocket Town's our ghetto. It's called Rocket Town because long ago, they put up a building there in which to build rockets. But none were built. And the building's now nothing, which is what it's always been, except for a fenced-off, dank corner that was once used to store dilapidated fire plugs and is now a filthy daycare for the children of parents who could care less.
火箭镇是我们的贫民窟。它之所以叫火箭镇，是因为很久以前，他们在那建了一座楼用来制造火箭。但什么也没造出来。那栋楼现在什么也不是，就像它一直以来的那样，除了一个被围起来、阴冷潮湿的角落，曾经用来存放破旧的消防栓，现在成了那些根本不在乎孩子的父母子女的肮脏托儿所。
All around Rocket Town, little houses went up when it was thought the building would soon be full of people making rockets and hauling down impressive wages. They're bad little houses, put up quick. And now all the people who were young and had hoped to build rockets are old and doddering and walk by the empty building mumbling, "Why, why, why?"
在火箭镇四周，那些小房子在人们以为那栋大楼很快就会挤满制造火箭、拿着高薪的人的时候建起来了。那些都是蹩脚的小房子，建得很快。而现在，那些曾经年轻、希望制造火箭的人们都已经老得颤颤巍巍，走过那座空楼时嘟囔着：“为什么，为什么，为什么？”
In the early days of my grief, Father Luther told me to lose myself in service by contacting ElderAid, Incorporated. I got Mrs. Ken Schwartz. Mrs. Ken Schwartz lives in Rocket Town. She lives in Rocket Town remembering Mr. Ken Schwartz and cursing him for staying so late at Menlo's Ten Pin on nights when she forgets he's been dead 18 years.
在我悲伤的早期，路德神父告诉我要通过联系“长者援助”公司在服务中迷失自我。我找到了肯·施瓦茨太太。肯·施瓦茨太太住在火箭镇。她住在火箭镇，在那些她忘了肯·施瓦茨先生已经死了18年的夜晚，咒骂他为什么在门洛十瓶保龄球馆待得那么晚。
Mrs. Ken Schwartz likes me and my happy modules. Especially she likes Viennese Waltz. Boy, does she. She's bedridden and lonely and sometimes, in her excitement, bruises her arms on her headboard when the orchestra starts to play.
肯·施瓦茨太太喜欢我和我的快乐模块。她特别喜欢《维也纳圆舞曲》。天哪，她是真的喜欢。她卧床不起，孤独一人，有时在兴奋中，当管弦乐队开始演奏时，她的手臂会撞伤床头板。
Tonight, she says she's feeling weak. She says she used to be a different person and wishes she could go back to the days when she was loved. She mourns Fat Patrice and their jovial games of Old Maid. She mourns the front yard oak the city felled without asking her. Mostly, she mourns Mr. Ken Schwartz.
今晚，她说她感觉很虚弱。她说她曾经是另一个人，希望能回到被爱的日子。她哀悼胖帕特里斯和他们快活的“老姑娘”游戏。她哀悼那棵城市没问她就砍掉的前院橡树。主要是，她哀悼肯·施瓦茨先生。
I pull out all the stops. I set color on high contrast. I tape sensors to her lips and earlobes. And I activate the royalty subroutine.
我使出浑身解数。我把色彩对比调到最高。我在她的嘴唇和耳垂上贴上传感器。我激活了皇室子程序。
Soon, the prince is lavishing her with praise. Soon, they're sneaking off from the ball for some tender words and a kiss or two on a stone bench beside the Danube. Soon, I'm daubing her eyes with tissue while she weeps at the beauty of the fishermen bowing from her little boats as they realize it's the prince himself trying to retrieve her corsage from the river.
很快，王子对她大加赞赏。很快，他们就从舞会上溜走，在多瑙河边的一条石凳上说些温柔的话，亲吻一两下。很快，我用纸巾擦拭她的眼睛，她因为看到渔夫们从他们的小船上鞠躬，意识到竟然是王子本人试图从河里为她取回胸花而感动的流泪。
I make tea. I read my magazine. Finally, I stroke her forehead while humming Strauss and slowly fading the volume. "You," she says, smiling sweetly when she's all the way back. "You're too good to me."
我沏茶。我看杂志。最后，我抚摸她的额头，哼着施特劳斯，慢慢调低音量。“你，”她微笑着，当她完全回来时甜美地说，“你对我太好了。”
"No one could be too good to you," I say.
“没人能对你太好，”我说。
"Oh, you," she says. "You're a saint."
“噢，你呀，”她说，“你真是个圣人。”
"No," I think, "I'm a man without a life, due to you." Then I feel ashamed and purposely bash my shin against a bed frame while tucking her in. I get her some juice. I check her back door lock. All around the room are dirty plates I've failed to get to the sink and old photos of Mr. Ken Schwartz assessing the condition of massive steam boilers while laughing confidently.
“不，”我想，“我是一个因为你而没有生活的人。”然后我感到羞愧，在给她盖被子时，故意把小腿撞在床架上。我给她拿了些果汁。我检查了她的后门锁。房间周围到处都是我没能洗的脏盘子，还有肯·施瓦茨先生评估大型蒸汽锅炉状况时自信大笑的旧照片。
Out on the street, it's cold. And a wino's standing in a dumpster, calling a stray cat Uncle Chuck. I hustle directly to my Omni, fearing for my gear. I drive through frightening quarters of the city, nervously toggling my defrost lever, thinking of Mrs. Schwartz.
街道上，天气很冷。一个酒鬼站在垃圾箱里，把一只流浪猫叫作查克叔叔。我赶快回到我的全能设备旁，担心我的装备。我开车穿过城市阴森的区域，神经质地切换除霜杆，想着施瓦茨太太。
The last few months, she's gone downhill. She's unable to feed herself or autonomously use the bathroom. Talk about losing yourself in service to a greater extent than planned. She needs a live-in, but they don't come cheap, and my shop hasn't turned a profit in months. What to do? I think and think. I think so much I lose track of where I am and blunder by the spot.
过去几个月，她的状况每况愈下。她无法自己进食，也无法自理厕所。谈论迷失自我服务比计划的程度要深得多。她需要一个住家护工，但那不便宜，我的店几个月没盈利了。怎么办？我想啊想。我想得太多，以至于忘记了我在哪里，跌跌撞撞地走到了那个地方。
"You fool," I think. "You ass. How much additional pain would you like?" Here, a drunk named Tom Clifton brought his Coupe Deville onto the sidewalk as Elizabeth shopped for fruit on the evening of a day when we'd fought like hell, on the evening of a day when I'd called her an awful name.
“你个傻瓜，”我想，“你个蠢货。你还想要多少额外的痛苦？”这里，一个叫汤姆·克利夫顿的醉汉把他的轿跑车开上了人行道，那天晚上我们吵得昏天黑地，那天晚上我曾叫过她一个糟糕的名字，那天晚上伊丽莎白正在买水果。
What name? I can't say the word. I even think it, and my gut burns. I'm a saint.
什么名字？我不能说出那个词。我甚至连想一下，我的胃都在烧。我真是个圣人。
The fight started when I accused her of flirting with our neighbor Len Kobb by bending low on purpose. I was angry and implied that she couldn't keep her boobs in her top to save her life. If I could see her one last time, I'd say, "Thanks very much for dying at the worst possible moment and leaving me holding the bag of guilt." I'd say, "If you had to die, couldn't you have done it when we were getting along?" I madly flee the spot.
争吵始于我指责她故意低身，和邻居伦·科布调情。我很生气，暗示她连自己的乳房都管不住。如果我能最后见她一次，我会说：“非常感谢你死在最糟糕的时刻，留给我一堆罪恶感。”我会说：“如果你非死不可，难道不能在我们和睦相处的时候吗？”我疯狂地逃离那个地方。
There are boat lights in the harbor and a man in a tux inexplicably jogging through the park. There's a moon bobbing up between condemned buildings. There's the fact that tomorrow, I'm Lay Authority Guest at the Lyndon Baines Johnson School for Precocious Youth. I'm slated to allow interested kids to experience the module entitled "Hop-Hop the Bunny Masters Fractions."
港口有船灯，一个穿着燕尾服的男人莫名其妙地在公园里慢跑。废弃的建筑物间有一个月亮在漂浮。还有一个事实是，明天我是林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊早熟青年学校的客座权威。我预定要让感兴趣的孩子体验名为“跳跳兔掌握分数”的模块。
Frankly, I fear I'll be sneered at. How interested could a mob of gifted kids be in a rabbit and a lisping caterpillar grouping acorns ad nauseam? But I promised the principal, Mrs. Briff. And I'm not in a position to decline any revenue source. So at an hour of the night when other men my age are rising from their beds to comfort screaming newborns, I return to the mall for my Hop-Hop module.
坦白说，我怕我会受到嘲笑。一群天才孩子对一只兔子和大舌头毛毛虫没完没了地数橡子会有多大兴趣？但我答应了校长布里夫太太。我没有立场拒绝任何收入来源。所以，在同龄人从床上爬起来安抚尖叫的新生儿的深夜，我回到商场拿我的跳跳兔模块。
More of George Saunders's story, "Offloading for Mrs. Schwartz," in a minute, when our program continues.
更多乔治·桑德斯的故事《帮施瓦茨太太卸载》，一分钟后，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and invite a variety of writers, performers, and documentary producers to tackle that theme. Today's theme, Get Over It. We continue now with George Saunders's story of a man who has not gotten over the death of his wife. It's late at night. He's stopping back at work to pick up modules of Hip-Hop the Bunny Masters Fractions to take to the school for School for Precocious Youth the next morning.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。今天的主题是“走出来”。我们现在继续乔治·桑德斯的故事，一个无法走出妻子死亡阴影的人。现在是深夜。他回单位取“跳跳兔掌握分数”模块，准备第二天带到早熟青年学校。
I use my pass key. Something's strange. Modules are strewn everywhere. The cash box sits on the fax machine. One of my treadmills lies on its side.
我用通行钥匙开门。有些奇怪。模块到处都是。现金盒放在传真机上。我的一台跑步机横躺着。
"How is all this fancy equipment used?" someone asks from behind me, pressing a sharp knife to my throat. "More specifically, which of it is worth the most? And remember, sir, you're answering for your life." He sounds old but feels strong.
“这些高级设备是怎么用的？”有人在我身后问，一把锋利的刀抵在我的喉咙上。“更具体地说，哪一个最值钱？记住，先生，你是在为你的生命回答。”他听起来很老，但力气很大。
I tell him it's hard to explain. I offer to demonstrate. He says, "Do so, but slowly." I fit him with a headset. I gently guide him to a treadmill then run Sexy Nurses Scrub You Down.
我告诉他很难解释。我提出演示一下。他说，“演示吧，但要慢点。”我给他戴上耳机。我轻轻引导他到跑步机旁，然后运行《性感护士为你擦洗》。
Immediately, his lips get moist. He loosens his grip on the knife, and I'm able to coldcock him with the FedEx tape gun. He drops drooling to my nice carpet.
立刻，他的嘴唇湿润了。他放松了对刀的握力，我得以用联邦快递的胶带枪把他打昏。他流着口水倒在我漂亮的毯子上。
A man his age should be a doting grandfather, not a crook threatening me with death. I feel violated. How does someone come to this?
他这个年纪的男人应该是个宠孙子的爷爷，而不是用死亡威胁我的坏蛋。我感到被侵犯了。一个人怎么会变成这样？
I strap him down and set my console for Scan. It seems his lousy name is Hank. I hear his portly father calling it out across a cranberry bog. I know the smell of his first baseball cap. Through his eyes, I see the secret place under the porch where he hid whenever his fat, kissing aunt came.
我把他绑起来，设置控制台进行扫描。看来他蹩脚的名字叫汉克。我听见他肥胖的父亲在蔓越莓沼泽对面呼唤这个名字。我熟悉他第一顶棒球帽的味道。透过他的眼睛，我看到了他在那个肥胖、爱亲吻的姑妈来时躲藏的门廊下的秘密地方。
Later, I develop a lot for swing. Seems he was a marine at Iwo who on his way to boot camp saw the aging Ty Cobb at a depot. I sense his panic on the troop transport and quickly doff my headset as he hits the beach and the bullets start to fly.
后来，我为他开发了一个摇摆模块。看来他曾是硫磺岛的海军陆战队员，在去新兵训练营的路上，他在仓库看到了老去的泰·柯布。我感受到他在运兵船上的恐慌，当他登陆沙滩，子弹开始乱飞时，我赶紧摘下耳机。
To my horror, I see that his eyelids are fluttering and his face is contorting. "My god," I think. "This is no scan. This is a damn offload." I check the console and sure enough, via one incorrect switch setting, I've just irrevocably transferred a good third of his memories to my hard drive.
让我恐惧的是，我看到他的眼皮在颤动，脸在扭曲。“我的上帝，”我想，“这不是扫描。这是一个该死的卸载。”我检查了控制台，果然，由于一个错误的开关设置，我刚刚无可挽回地把他好三分之一的记忆转移到了我的硬盘上。
He comes to and hops off the table looking years younger, suddenly happy-go-lucky, asks where he is, and trots blithely out the door, free now of boot camp, free of Iwo, free of all memory of youthful slaughter, free, in fact, of any memory at all of the first 20 years of his life. I'm heartsick. What have I done? On the other hand, it stopped him from getting up and trying to kill me. On the other hand, it appears he left here a happier man, perhaps less inclined to felony.
他醒来跳下桌子，看起来年轻了几岁，突然变得无忧无虑，问他在哪儿，然后轻快地跑出门去，摆脱了新兵营，摆脱了硫磺岛，摆脱了关于战争屠杀的记忆，事实上，摆脱了关于他生命前20年的任何记忆。我心如刀绞。我做了什么？另一方面，这阻止了他起来试图杀我。另一方面，看来他离开时是个更快乐的人，也许没那么容易犯罪了。
I grab my Hop-Hop module. On the cover is Hop-Hop, enthusiastically giving the thumbs up to an idealized blond boy lifting an enormous four into a numerator. As if being robbed weren't enough, first thing tomorrow morning, a room full of genius kids is going to eat me alive.
我抓起我的跳跳兔模块。封面上是跳跳兔热情地向一个理想化的金发男孩竖起大拇指，他正在把一个巨大的四提到分子位置。仿佛被抢劫还不够，明天一早，满屋子的天才孩子就要把我活吞了。
Then crossing a deserted food court, I get a brainstorm. I hustle back to the shop and edit out Hank's trysts with starving women in Depression-era hobo camps and his one homo fling with his cousin, Julian. I edit the profanity out of Iwo. I edit out the midnight wanks, the petty thefts, the unkind words, all but the most inoffensive of the bodies of his buddies on the pale sand beach.
然后穿过空荡荡的食品广场，我灵光一闪。我赶紧回到店里，剪掉了汉克和大萧条时期流浪汉营地饥饿女人的私通，以及他和表弟朱利安的一次同性狂欢。我剪掉了硫磺岛的脏话。我剪掉了午夜手淫、小偷小摸、恶言恶语，只留下了他在惨白沙滩上同伴尸体中最不冒犯的部分。
The next morning, I herd kid after kid behind my white curtain and let them experience Hank's life. They love it. The leave jabbering knowledgeably about the Pacific theater and the ultimate wisdom of using the bomb. They leave praising Phil Rizzuto's Fielding and cursing the brownshirts.
第二天早上，我把一个又一个孩子赶到我的白窗帘后面，让他们体验汉克的生活。他们爱死它了。他们离开时滔滔不绝地讨论太平洋战场以及使用原子弹的终极智慧。他们离开时赞美菲尔·里祖托的守备，诅咒褐衫军。
They pat old Mr. Panchuko, the geriatric janitor, on the back and ask him what caliber machine going he operated at the Bulge. He stands scratching his gut, stunned, trying to remember. The little Klotchkow twins jitterbug. Andy Pitlin, all of three feet tall, hankers aloud for a Camel.
他们拍拍老潘丘科先生（老年痴呆的看门人）的背，问他在突出部战役中操作的是什么口径的机枪。他站在那儿抓着肚子，惊呆了，试图回忆。小克洛奇科夫双胞胎在跳吉特巴舞。只有三英尺高的安迪·皮特林大声渴望着一根骆驼牌香烟。
Mrs. Briff is more than impressed. She asks what else I have. I ask what else does she want. She says for starters, how about the remainder of the century. I tell her I'll see what I can do.
布里夫太太印象深刻。她问我还有什么。我问她还想要什么。她说起码，剩下那个世纪怎么样。我告诉她我会看看能做什么。
The kids come out of it with a firsthand War Years experience, and I come out of it with a check for $500, enough to hire a temporary live-in for Mrs. Ken Schwartz, which I gladly do. A lovely Eurasian named Wei, a student of astrophysics who, as I'm leaving them alone for the first time, is brushing out Mrs. Ken Schwartz's hair and humming "Let Me Call You Sweetheart." "Will you stay forever?" I ask her.
孩子们从中获得了亲身的战争岁月体验，而我则得到了500美元的支票，足以雇一个临时住家护工照顾肯·施瓦茨太太，我欣然照办。一个可爱的欧亚裔女孩，名叫魏，是天体物理学专业的学生，当我第一次留他们单独相处时，她正在帮肯·施瓦茨太太梳头，哼着《让我叫你亲爱的》。“你会永远留下吗？”我问她。
"With all due respect," she replies, "I will stay as long as you can pay me."
“恕我直言，”她回答，“只要你付得起工资，我就留下来。”
Two weeks later, Briff's on my tail for more modules, and Wei's on my tail for her pay. I tell Mrs. Ken Schwartz all during one of her 15-minute windows of lucidity. When lucid, she's shrewd and bright. She understands her predicament. She understands the limitations of my gear. She understands that I can't borrow her memories, only take them away forever. She says she can live without the '60s.
两周后，布里夫为了更多模块找我麻烦，魏为了工资找我麻烦。我在肯·施瓦茨太太15分钟清醒时间中的一次，告诉了她所有事情。当清醒时，她精明而聪明。她理解自己的处境。她理解我设备的局限性。她理解我不能借用她的记忆，只能永远夺走它们。她说她可以没有60年代。
I haul my stuff over to her place and take what I need. I edit out her mastectomy, Ken Schwartz's midlife crisis and resulting trip to Florida, and her constant drinking in his absence. I stick to her walking past a protest and counseling a skinny girl on acid to stay in school. It's not great, but I've got a deadline. I call it America in Tumult, The Older Generation Looks On in Dismay. I have it couriered over to Briff, dreading her response.
我把东西搬到她家，拿走我需要的。我剪掉了她的乳房切除手术、肯·施瓦茨的更年期危机导致的佛罗里达之行，以及他在她缺席时的不断酗酒。我只留下了她走过抗议人群，建议一个吸毒的瘦女孩留在学校的部分。虽然不是很好，但我有截止日期。我把它叫做《美国动荡，老一辈的惊恐注视》。我派快递送给布里夫，担心她的反应。
But to my amazement, she sends a cash bonus. she reports astounding increases in grandparental bonding. She reports kids identifying a Mercury Cougar with no prompting and disgustedly calling each other Nixon whenever a trust is betrayed.
但让我震惊的是，她寄来了现金奖金。她报告了祖孙羁绊的惊人增长。她报告孩子们看到水星美洲狮轿车时不需要提示就能认出来，并且在信任被背叛时厌恶地称对方为“尼克松”。
Thereafter, I retained Wei on a weekly basis by whittling away at Mrs. Schwartz's memories. I submit Pearl Harbor, Week Prior to Infamy. I submit The Day the Music Died, Buddy Holly Remembered, which unfortunately is merely Mrs. Schwartz hearing the news on a pink radio then disinterestedly going back to cleaning her oven.
此后，我通过削减施瓦茨太太的记忆，每周留用魏。我提交了《珍珠港，耻辱周》。我提交了《音乐死去的那天，巴迪·霍利回忆录》，不幸的是，那仅仅是施瓦茨太太在粉红色的收音机上听到新闻，然后心不在焉地回去清理烤箱。
Finally, Briff calls, hacked off. She say she wants some real meat. She asks, how about the entire '20s, a personal favorite of hers. She's talking flappers. She's talking possible insights on Prohibition. I stonewall. I tell her, give me a few days to exhaustively check my massive archive.
最后，布里夫打电话来，发火了。她说她要点真东西。她问，整个20年代怎么样，那是她个人的最爱。她在说飞女郎。她在说关于禁酒令的见解。我拖延了。我告诉她，给我几天时间彻底检查我的大型档案。
I call Mrs. Ken Schwartz. She says during the '20s, she was a lowly phone operator in Pekin, Illinois. She sounds disoriented and wearily asks where her breasts are. Clearly, this has gone far enough.
我打电话给肯·施瓦茨太太。她说在20年代，她是伊利诺伊州皮金的一个卑微的电话接线员。她听起来很迷茫，疲惫地问她的乳房在哪儿。显然，这已经够过分的了。
I call Briff and tell her no more modules. She ups her offer to $3,000 a decade. She's running for school board and says my modules are the primary arrow in her quiver. But what am I supposed to do, turn Mrs. Schwartz into a well-cared-for blank slate? Start kidnapping and offloading strangers? I say a little prayer.
我打电话给布里夫，告诉她不再提供模块。她把报价提高到每十年3000美元。她要竞选校董会，说我的模块是她箭袋里的主要箭矢。但我该怎么办，把施瓦茨太太变成一个照顾得很好的白板？开始绑架和卸载陌生人？我做了个小祷告。
"God, I've botched this life but good. I've failed you in all major ways. You gave me true love, and I blew it. I'm nothing. But what have you got against Mrs. Ken Schwartz? Forgive me. Help me figure this out." And then in a flash, I figure it out.
“上帝，我把这辈子搞得一团糟。我在所有重大方面都让你失望了。你给了我真爱，我却搞砸了。我什么也不是。但你和肯·施瓦茨太太有什么仇？原谅我。帮我弄明白这一切。”然后在一瞬间，我想明白了。
I lock the shop. On the spine of a blank module I write 1951 to 1992, Baby Boomers Come Into Their Own. At $3,000 a decade, that's 12 grand. I address an envelope to Briff and enclose an invoice. I write out some instructions and rig myself up.
我锁上店门。在空白模块的脊上，我写道《1951年至1992年，婴儿潮一代开始崛起》。按每十年3000美元算，那是1万2千块。我给布里夫写了个信封，附上发票。我写下一些说明，把自己装好。
"Memories, schmemories," I think. "I'll get some new ones. These old ones give me no peace." Then I let it rip.
“记忆，去他的记忆，”我想，“我会得到一些新的。这些旧的没给我带来安宁。”然后我放手一搏。
It all goes whizzing by. Anthony Newburg smacking me, Mom on the dock, an Agnew Halloween mask at a frat house. Bev Malloy struggling with my belt. The many seasons, the many flags, dogs, paths, the many stars and the skies of many hues.
这一切飞快地掠过。安东尼·纽伯格打我，妈妈在码头，兄弟会里的阿格纽万圣节面具。贝夫·马洛伊挣扎着扯我的腰带。许多季节，许多旗帜、狗、道路、许多星星和各种色调的天空。
My sweet Elizabeth. Holding hands, we gape at an elk in Estes Park. On our knees, in a bed of tulips, I kiss her cheek. The cold, clear water of Nacogdoches. The birthday banner she made of scarves in our little place on Ellington. The awful look on her faces as I called her what I called her. Her hair trailing fine and light behind her as she stormed out to buy fruit. The grave, the grave, my sad attempt to become a franchisee.
我甜蜜的伊丽莎白。我们手牵手，在埃斯特斯公园盯着一只麋鹿。在郁金香花丛中，我们跪着，我吻她的脸颊。纳科格多奇斯清凉的水。她在埃灵顿我们那个小窝里用围巾做的生日横幅。当我叫她那个名字时，她脸上可怕的表情。当她冲出去买水果时，她那细长头发在身后飘动。坟墓，坟墓，我试图成为特许经营商的悲伤尝试。
Then I'm a paunchy guy in a room with a note pinned to his sleeve. "You were alone in the world," it says, "and did a kindness for someone in need. Good for you. Now post this module and follow this map to the home of Mrs. Ken Schwartz. Care for her with some big money that will come in the mail. Find someone to love. Your heart has never been broken. You've never done anything unforgivable or hurt anyone beyond reparation. Everyone you've ever loved, you've treated like gold."
然后我是一个大腹便便的家伙，在房间里，袖子上别着一张纸条。“你在这个世界上是孤独的，”它写道，“并且对一个需要的人做了件善事。这很好。现在寄出这个模块，跟随这张地图去肯·施瓦茨太太家。用邮寄来的大钱照顾她。找个人去爱。你的心从未破碎过。你从未做过任何不可原谅的事，也没伤害过任何无法补偿的人。你爱过的每一个人，你都像珍宝一样对待。”
George Saunders's story is from his book, CivilWarLand in Bad Decline. He teaches at Syracuse University.
乔治·桑德斯的故事摘自他的书《内战乐园在衰退》。他在雪城大学任教。
Act Three, Finding Amnesia. Who among us, wanting to get over it, has not wanted amnesia? But one thing about amnesia, one frustrating thing, is that it seems to happen a lot more in television and movies and novels than it ever does in real life. I have here an article from Romantic Times Magazine, April of 1996. They list here 40 different romance novels that are on the shelves now where amnesia is the plotline.
第三幕，寻找失忆。我们之中，那些想要走出来的人，谁没想过失忆呢？但关于失忆，一件令人沮丧的事情是，它在电视、电影和小说中发生的次数似乎比现实生活中多得多。我这里有一篇《浪漫时代杂志》，1996年4月的文章。他们列出了现在书架上的40本不同浪漫小说，其中失忆都是情节主线。
But does it really happen? Have you ever met anybody who it happens to? Well, we asked reporter Scott Carrier in Salt Lake City to find out if it does really happen.
但它真的会发生吗？你见过失忆的人吗？嗯，我们请盐湖城的记者斯科特·卡里尔去看看它是否真的会发生。
The idea was to find someone who had amnesia and ask them what it was like in real life. I was warned that it might be difficult to locate such a person, that the affliction may in reality be quite rare, but that there was at least one known amnesiac living in Tennessee and another in Pennsylvania. The particular cities and addresses could be found if necessary. "Nonsense," I said. "I'm surrounded by amnesiacs. This city breeds forgetfulness. There must be five or six amnesiacs in the neighborhood around my office alone." I accepted the offer, thinking it would be an easy assignment.
初衷是找到一个失忆的人，问问他们在现实生活中是什么感觉。我被警告说找到这样的人可能很困难，这种病在现实中可能相当罕见，但至少有一个已知的失忆症患者住在田纳西州，另一个住在宾夕法尼亚州。如果有必要，可以找到具体的城市和地址。“胡说，”我说，“我的周围到处都是失忆症患者。这座城市滋生健忘。单是在我办公室周围的街区里，肯定就有五六个失忆者。”我接受了这个任务，以为这会是一项轻松的工作。
I began by asking everybody I saw if they had or had ever had amnesia. I did this for three days. And I tried not to be selective, but to ask everybody with whom I came into contact, whether my wife or the checker at the grocery store. "Do you have or have you ever had amnesia?" And furthermore, I'd ask this each and every time I saw the person, sometimes two or three times a day.
我开始问我看到的每个人，他们是否有过失忆。我坚持了三天。我尽量不挑选对象，而是问每一个与我接触的人，无论是我的妻子还是杂货店的收银员。“你有过或曾经有过失忆吗？”而且，每次我见到这个人时都会问，有时一天问两三次。
No one admitted to currently having amnesia, but at least one in four remembered being knocked hard on the head and losing memory from a concussion. This kind of amnesia lasts only a few minutes or a few hours, and concussion stories, I found out, are usually not worth listening to or worth telling. They usually go something like this.
没人承认自己现在失忆，但四分之一的人记得头被重击过，并因脑震荡而失去记忆。这种失忆通常只持续几分钟或几小时，而且我发现，脑震荡的故事通常不值得听，也不值得讲。它们通常是这样的。
"I was in a football game, and two guys fell on my head. I kept playing. I played the whole game and everything. But then after the game, I had to get a ride home, because I didn't remember where I lived."
“我当时在踢一场橄榄球赛，两个人砸到了我的头上。我继续踢。我踢完了整场比赛，什么都做了。但比赛后，我得搭车回家，因为我不记得我住哪儿了。”
I heard this story three times from the same person. And each time, he told it to me in the same way, with some difficulty, as if something had been taken from him, and he didn't know what it was.
同样的故事我从同一个人那里听了三次。每次他都用同样的方式讲给我听，带着些许困难，仿佛有什么东西被从他身上拿走了，而他不知道那是什么。
Two people admitted to suffering from drug-induced amnesia. One had a drinking problem. The other was myself, as, due to the fact that when I was 19, I ate a big, psilocybin mushroom right off the ground in the mountains of Colombia, South America and spent four or five hours where I didn't know my name, where I was, or why.
两个人承认患有药物诱导的失忆症。一个有酗酒问题。另一个是我自己，因为当我19岁时，我在哥伦比亚安第斯山脉生吃了一个巨大的致幻蘑菇，度过了四五个小时，期间我不知道自己的名字、我在哪里，或者为什么在那。
I was hallucinating wildly, the sky exploding, the ground bubbling up under my feet. The trees and bushes were throwing off little packets of flame and brightly colored orbs. I wandered around and around in a cow pasture, holding my hands over my eyes, delirious.
我产生了剧烈的幻觉，天空爆炸，地面在我脚下冒泡。树木和灌木丛喷射出小团火焰和五颜六色的球体。我在牛场里来回徘徊，双手捂着眼睛，神志不清。
And then a man in a Jeep picked me up. And I thought he might be my father. And I thought I knew what he was saying. But I didn't know what language he was speaking.
然后一个开吉普车的男人接了我。我觉得他可能是我父亲。我觉得我听懂了他在说什么。但我不知道他在说什么语言。
And we went to his house and watched the soccer game on television while his wife, who I thought might be my mother, served us coffee from a metal tray. And then I was back out on the road. And I walked up to a park and sat down and drew a picture myself in a notebook. And below the picture, I wrote these words. "I'm still here." If this gave me any insights into what amnesia is like, real amnesia, I don't remember what they are.
我们去了他家，看着电视上的足球比赛，而我觉得可能是我的母亲的妻子，用金属托盘给我们端咖啡。然后我又回到了路上。我走到公园，坐下来，在笔记本上画了自己的画。在画下面，我写了这些字：“我还在这里。”如果这给了我任何关于失忆是什么感觉、真正的失忆是什么感觉的启示，我不记得它们是什么了。
In three days, the closest I came to finding someone with amnesia was through a young woman who's the daughter of a friend of mine. She's a physical therapist, and one of her patients had had her smashed in a car accident. Her amnesia is kind of the opposite of what we normally think about. She can remember things in the distant past just fine. But she doesn't seem to be able to remember what just happened, or what she was just thinking, or just where it was she was going.
三天里，我最接近找到失忆者的经历是通过一位朋友的女儿，她是一名理疗师，她的一个病人被车撞坏了。她的失忆症与我们通常认为的相反。她能很好地记住过去遥远的事情。但她似乎无法记住刚刚发生了什么，或者她刚才在想什么，或者她要去哪里。
So she can't, for instance, drive a car or even ride a bus. I asked my friend's daughter if I might be able to talk with this woman. And she said, "Well, I guess so. But you might have a better conversation with her dog."
所以，她不能开车，甚至不能坐公交车。我问朋友的女儿我是否能和这个女人聊聊。她说，“嗯，我想可以。但你可能和她的狗交流会更好。”
I came back to my office feeling a little down. Finding an amnesiac was proving to be more difficult than expected. I decided to seek professional help. I got up out of my chair and walked across the hallway and knocked on the door of Dr. Jeff Harris, psychologist.
我回到办公室，感到有点沮丧。寻找失忆症患者比预想的要困难得多。我决定寻求专业帮助。我从椅子上站起来，走到走廊对面，敲开了心理医生杰夫·哈里斯的门。
I think there was a guy that went through it when I was in Vietnam. He ended up in some serious action and ended up going from one APC to the next. And each one got blown up as he was getting in or-- and I don't know exactly how he survived the whole thing. But we're talking about a platoon basically getting wiped out, he being one of the few survivors.
我想我在越南时有个家伙经历过那个。他最终参与了一些严重的行动，从一辆装甲车转到下一辆。每辆车在他进去时都被炸毁了，我不知道他是怎么活下来的。但我们说的是一个排基本被消灭了，他是少数幸存者之一。
And he couldn't remember. He couldn't remember his past. He couldn't remember where he was going. Yeah, that's the classical Freudian theory of repression. We don't remember things that make us feel guilty or feel pain.
他记不住。他记不住他的过去。他记不住他要往哪儿去。是的，这就是经典的弗洛伊德压抑理论。我们记不住那些让我们感到内疚或痛苦的事情。
All right. Well, let me ask you this. Say I have the ability to make you have amnesia. If I flip the switch, you won't remember your name. You won't remember who you are. What do you think?
好吧，那我问你这个。假设我有能力让你失忆。如果我拨动开关，你不记得你的名字了。你不记得你是谁了。你怎么想？
What do I think?
你怎么想？
Yeah, would you do it or not?
是的，你会做还是不做？
Would you?
你会吗？
I would want to do it because then I think that I would lose my ego. I would have a clean slate.
我想做，因为那样我觉得我会失去我的自我。我会有个清白之身。
If all of a sudden, you sat here and you couldn't remember why you were holding this microphone or who I am or why you're talking to me, to say that was disorienting would be too mild.
如果突然，你坐在这里，你不记得为什么你拿着这个麦克风，或者我是谁，或者为什么你跟我说话，说那是令人迷惑的，那都太轻描淡写了。
I think I would be smart enough to realize this is a gift. There's two choices. Either you realize that it's a gift, or you completely freak out. One or the other.
我觉得我会足够聪明地意识到这是一个礼物。有两种选择。要么你意识到这是一个礼物，要么你彻底崩溃。要么这样，要么那样。
But you're talking as if you wake up in the morning. You don't know where you are, who you are, where in the hell you're going, and you're happy with it? Give me a goddamn break.
但你说的好像你早上醒来。你不知道你在哪儿，你是谁，你到底要去哪儿，而你对此很满意？饶了我吧，老天。
That still seems attractive to me. It still seems like it might be a good thing. To be put in a situation where I have to admit that I'm completely lost seems like--
那对我来说仍然很有吸引力。它看起来仍然像是一件好事。陷入一种我必须承认我彻底迷失的情况，看起来好像——
Oh, I think you already are, Scott.
噢，我觉得你已经是了，斯科特。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
After five days, having found no one who had or had had amnesia, I decided to visit a hypnotherapist, Diane Bradshaw, and ask her if she could give me amnesia. She said she probably could do it, as long as I was willing to be put under hypnosis. She said some people just weren't willing.
五天后，没有找到任何失忆过的人，我决定去拜访一位催眠治疗师，黛安·布拉德肖，问她能不能让我失忆。她说她大概能做到，只要我愿意被催眠。她说有些人就是不愿意。
And if you're open to the possibility that, say, amnesia would be OK for five minutes or one minute, it might happen.
而且如果你对“失忆五分钟或一分钟没关系”这种可能性持开放态度，它可能会发生。
Well, I'm open to even a day. Would that be a bad idea?
嗯，我甚至对一天都持开放态度。那会是个坏主意吗？
What do you really want here? Do you want to get that extreme?
你在这里到底想要什么？你想要那么极端吗？
Let's say a few hours anyway. What do you think? Because he's going to have to hang out with me.
让我们说几个小时吧。你怎么想？因为他得跟我混在一起。
You know what I think?
你知道我怎么想吗？
I think an hour.
我觉得一个小时。
I think if you had a half hour of amnesia, you would get it pretty quick.
我觉得如果你有半小时的失忆，你会很快恢复的。
OK. All right. An hour. A half hour.
好吧。好吧。一个小时。半个小时。
I think a half hour would probably be plenty of time. And then I have to ask you, what do you want to forget? I can do anything from giving you a suggestion to forget your name, to forget where you live, to-- what do you want to forget?
我觉得半小时的时间可能足够了。然后我得问你，你想忘记什么？我可以做任何事，从建议你忘记名字，到忘记住哪儿，到——你想忘记什么？
Is it possible to forget everything, my whole self-identity? Is that too much?
有可能忘记一切，我整个自我的身份吗？那是不是太多了？
Well, I--
嗯，我——
She took notes on what I wanted to forget. Then she hypnotized me, which involved having me count backwards from 100 and telling me to relax deeper and deeper, and then having me imagine being in a big garden with a stream running through it. And she said if I drank from the stream, I'd forget my name and where I was, and also the name of my friend who'd come with me. So I went and drank from the stream. And she woke me up.
她记下了我想忘记的东西。然后她催眠了我，让我从100开始倒数，告诉我放松，越放松越深，然后让我想象身处一个有溪流穿过的大花园里。她说如果我喝溪里的水，我会忘记我的名字和我在哪儿，还有和我一起来的朋友的名字。所以我去喝了水。然后她唤醒了我。
Five, open your eyes, all the way back, emerging from hypnosis, all the way back. Hi there.
五，睁开眼睛，完全回来，从催眠中浮现，完全回来。你好啊。
Hi.
你好。
How you doing?
你感觉怎么样？
Good.
好。
Feels pretty good, doesn't it?
感觉不错，不是吗？
It was pleasant.
挺愉快的。
Yeah.
是的。
It was fun. But I think I can remember. I'm sorry.
很有趣。但我认为我能记起来。抱歉。
And what is it you can remember? What town do you live in?
那你记得什么？你住在哪个城市？
Salt Lake, sorry.
盐湖城，抱歉。
And what have you been doing today?
你今天都在做什么？
Um, working on this story.
嗯，在写这个故事。
And what's his name over here?
那这边这位叫什么名字？
Trent Harris.
特伦特·哈里斯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm sorry, man. I tried. I did. I tried.
我很抱歉，伙计。我试过了。我做到了。我试过了。
The next day, I typed amnesia into a search engine on the World Wide Web and got a phone number for the Beckman Institute, a neuroscience center at the University of Illinois. I called up and talked to Rob Althoff, a graduate student. And he told me that the kind of amnesia I was looking for was indeed very rare and that there's some disagreement over whether it even happens at all.
第二天，我在互联网搜索引擎上输入“失忆”，得到了伊利诺伊大学神经科学中心贝克曼研究所的电话号码。我打过去，和研究生罗布·奥尔索夫谈了谈。他告诉我，我正在寻找的那种失忆症确实非常罕见，而且关于它是否会发生，人们存在一些分歧。
He said people do suffer long-term memory loss from severe brain injuries, but that usually, these people never recover their memories, that their brain doesn't regenerate. And he said that the other kind of amnesia, where there's no physical trauma, is often a matter of the person not wanting to remember, for one psychological reason or another, and that in these cases, it's really difficult to know whether the person is basically just faking it.
他说人们确实会因为严重的脑损伤而长期失忆，但通常，这些人永远无法恢复记忆，他们的大脑不会再生。他还说，另一种没有生理创伤的失忆症，往往是因为当事人出于某种心理原因不想记住，在这些情况下，真的很难判断当事人是否只是在装模作样。
Talking to Althoff made me wonder if amnesia, the kind we see on TV and in the movies, where a character gets hit on the head with a coconut, loses his self-identity and then spends the rest of the story rediscovering it or getting bonked on the head by another coconut, whether this is really just a story that we want to be true, that we somehow want to believe in it. The next thing I did was call Diane Bradshaw back and ask her if she knew anyone who could be easily hypnotized and wouldn't mind having amnesia. And she said yes, he's coming by this afternoon. If you came by around 4:00, we could ask him.
和奥尔索夫的谈话让我怀疑，我们在电视和电影里看到的那种失忆——角色被椰子砸到头，失去自我身份，然后花余下时间去重新发现或者又被另一个椰子砸头——这种失忆是不是只是一个我们希望是真的故事，我们不知何故想要相信它。我做的下一件事是给黛安·布拉德肖回电话，问她是否认识容易被催眠而且不介意失忆的人。她说是的，他今天下午会来。如果你4点左右过来，我们可以问问他。
So I went back and met Doug. And Doug was not only willing to be hypnotized, he told me that he'd actually had amnesia 10 years ago in Hawaii.
所以我回去见了道格。道格不仅愿意被催眠，他还告诉我10年前在夏威夷他真的失忆过。
I was on my way from Haleiwa, which is the north shore of Hawaii. And I was on my way in to Waikiki. And there was a guy standing on the side of the road that had a towel wrapped around his head and had chicken blood, or I don't know what kind of blood. But he pulled over. He waved me over. And I pulled over my Volkswagen van.
我从夏威夷北岸的哈雷瓦出发。我正要去威基基。路边站着一个头上裹着毛巾的家伙，身上沾着鸡血，或者我不知道是什么血。但他靠边停车了。他向我招手。我把我的大众面包车靠边停了。
And a bunch of guys came out of the cane field. And they just beat me. They beat me senseless. They broke almost every rib on the one side, punctured my lung with one of the ribs, punctured my lung, broke my jaw, broke my nose, and robbed me.
一群人从甘蔗地里冲了出来。他们就开始打我。他们把我打得不省人事。他们打断了几乎所有肋骨的一侧，用其中一根肋骨刺穿了我的肺，刺穿了我的肺，打断了我的下巴，打断了我的鼻子，抢劫了我。
I was out. And they took me to the hospital, and I didn't regain consciousness for over 20 days. 21 days was when I finally woke up.
我不省人事了。他们把我送到医院，我昏迷了20多天。第21天我才终于醒来。
So what was it like when you woke up?
那你醒来时是什么感觉？
I was scared. I've never been that scared in my life. I just didn't know how I got to where I was or who I was. And then as soon as I started to feel comfortable, just even a little bit comfortable, then I kind of was excited. I wanted to know everything. I wanted to know what this was and just everything. Because food, that was really wild. When they brought me ice cream, I was, "Woo-hoo, boy, this is good. I like this. Bring more of this."
我很害怕。我这辈子从没那么害怕过。我根本不知道我是怎么到那儿的，或者我是谁。然后一旦我开始感到舒适，哪怕是一点点舒适，我就有点兴奋了。我想知道一切。我想知道这是什么，什么都要知道。因为食物，那真的很疯狂。当他们给我拿来冰淇淋时，我，“呜呼，伙计，这太棒了。我喜欢这个。再多来点。”
So you couldn't remember food. You couldn't remember words, even. What kinds of things could you remember?
所以你不记得食物。你甚至不记得词汇。你记得什么东西？
I remember I talked kind of a baby talk kind of thing, where it was a broken making words. My mind would think the word, but it wouldn't come down to my mouth. And I would-- [SLURRED SPEECH] --kinda talk like, like that, like that.
我记得我讲的是那种婴儿语，说话支离破碎。我的脑子想到了词，但嘴里说不出来。然后我就——[模糊不清的语音]——有点那样说，那样说。
It didn't take long for Diane to hypnotize him. He went down like a rock.
黛安没花多久就把他催眠了。他像块石头一样倒下。
In a moment, I'm going to say "wide awake." When I do, you will have no memory of who you are or where you are, gone completely. Wide awake. Open your eyes, wide awake. Hi there. What's your name? Where are you?
过一会儿，我会说“完全清醒”。当我这么做的时候，你将不会记得你是谁或者你在哪儿，完全消失。完全清醒。睁开眼睛，完全清醒。你好啊。你叫什么名字？你在哪儿？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You don't know. Did you know when you came in here?
你不知道。你进来时知道吗？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
You don't remember. Yeah.
你不记得了。是的。
Ask him how it feels to not know who he is.
问问他不知道自己是谁是什么感觉。
Yeah. So hi. What's your name?
好的。所以你好。你叫什么名字？
I don't know.
我不知道。
What's it like not to know?
不知道是什么感觉？
It's black.
是黑色的。
How does that blackness make you feel? When you say black, what's the emotion?
那种黑色让你感觉如何？当你说黑色时，情绪是什么？
Puzzled, and it's like I'm waiting for the projector to start at a movie. Like it's not on yet.
困惑，就像我在电影放映机启动前等着一样。好像它还没开始。
Watching Doug go through this, I couldn't decide whether it was real amnesia or whether it was just a performance of amnesia, and that maybe there's no difference. Doug said that getting beat up and losing his memory did help him turn his life around. If that's what he needed, if that's what we all need at some level, then it's no wonder people pretend it's more common than it really is.
看着道格经历这些，我无法决定这是真实的失忆还是仅仅是失忆的表演，也许两者没有区别。道格说，被打和失去记忆确实帮助他改变了人生。如果那是他需要的，如果那是我们所有人某种程度上需要的，那么难怪人们假装它比现实中更常见。
Scott Carrier lives in Salt Lake City.
斯科特·卡里尔住在盐湖城。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors for this show, Margy Rochlin, Jack Hitt, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs our website.
好了，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我制作，彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克参与。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。本节目的特约编辑，玛吉·罗克林、杰克·希特和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。感谢经营我们网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our shows, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的 WBEZ 电台，312-832-3380。或者你可以通过我们的网站 www.thislife.org 在互联网上免费收听我们的大部分节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. And what exactly is management oversight?
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。究竟什么是管理监督？
I edit out the midnight wanks, the petty thefts, the unkind words.
我剪掉了午夜手淫、小偷小摸、恶言恶语。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。